you know I need to stop for a second as
we start this hour and just review
exactly what we teach and why so that
you'll know because sometimes people
read one of our books or go through the
class or listen to this show and they
don't hear exactly what we teach and why
so let's review that for a second we
have learned that if you do five things
with money that your grandmother talked
about and the Bible covers biblical
methods of handling money if you do
these five things over a long period of
time 15 or 20 years while earning an
income you will become wealthy a level
of wealth will be built now the income
that you make will dictate some of that
and how much tragedy you face during
that 15 or 20 years will dictate some of
that I can't predict those two things
but I can predict 100% of time if you
follow these five principles you will
build a level of wealth what are the
five principles you live on a written
plan a written plan every month before
the month begins every dollar has a name
jesus said don't build a tower without
first counting the cost list you get
halfway up and you're unable to finish
and all who see you begin to mock you
and say this man began to build and was
unable to finish you need to save money
first for emergencies second for
purchases to avoid debt and third to
build wealth in retirement in college
you need to learn to save money the
Bible says in the house of the wise our
stores of choice food and oil if you
don't save money and you don't have a
plan you will not build wealth third you
need to get out of debt because when you
don't have any payments you have money
the borrower is slave to the lender your
most powerful wealth building tool is
your income when you give it all to the
stupid bank you have no money and you
call that a life you work for somebody
else and you run run run run run like a
rat in a wheel and all the money that
you earn is given to someone else every
month and you get to drive around the
banks car you know that's why they have
drive up windows at the bank so the bank
can see so the car can see its real
owner ever so often that's why they're
there so you need to get to the
position that you actually get out of
the business of being a borrower because
the borrower is slave to the lender you
need to be outrageous in your giving
generous people are financially
successful selfish people very very
seldom are there's a few examples but
very seldom so if you live on a plan you
stay out of debt you save money you're
generous beyond belief you'll begin to
build wealth it'll happen
and you need to the last one is you need
to be invested in quality relationships
you become who you hang around with if
you hang around with people with a
filthy mouth you're going to have a
filthy mouth if you hang around with
people they have an accent you're going
to have an accent I was up north the
other day I noticed a whole bunch of you
have an accent you become who you hang
around with if the people you run around
with read books you're going to be a
reader of books if the people you run
around with their entire understanding
of intellectual behavior is People
magazine and who got thrown off the
island you're what's known as shallow
and typical and you're not going to win
think about it you become who you run
around with you don't let your kids run
around juvenile delinquents you know why
because they become a juvenile
delinquent little Johnny down the street
smoking weed your kid hangs out with
little Johnny your kids going to be a
weed head like little Johnny you know
that about little Johnny and you know
that about your kid why are you
different you become who you hang around
with this is not rocket science folks
you do those five things you'll win with
money and then we took those five and
wove them into the baby steps
don't do anything until you do baby step
one that's why we call it baby step one
because it's first you don't do anything
you stop all investing all saving you
stop all investing even if there's a
match and all saving until you get a
thousand dollars in the bank that's baby
step one a starter emergency fund once
you've got your thousand dollars you
still don't do anything with money I
don't want you doing anything with money
did I mention I don't want you to do
anything with money except baby step two
until baby step two is done baby step
two is you pay off all of your debts
except your home listing your debts
smallest to largest pay minimum pay
it's on everything but the little one
and attack the little one with a
vengeance
I mean go crazy so so much stuff the
kids think they're next
quit investing stop saving stop paying
extra on anything except that smallest
debt pay minimum payments on everything
but the little one and attack the little
one with a vengeance when that did it
when all those debts are gone everything
but the house and by the way people
following this plan using the Total
Money Makeover listening to this show
going through Financial Peace University
or paying off their debts 100 percent
the average person is debt free except
their home in two years or less the
average person now that some take longer
some take less that's the average that's
why they call it an average in two years
you could be debt-free if you focused on
nothing else people do it all the time
now when you don't have any payments can
accept your home can you breathe that
one in I don't have any payments with my
house can you just think about what that
feel like you already feel lighter you
already feel different think about it no
payments then and only then do you start
saving money again did I mention you
don't save money while you're getting
out of debt why because total focus is
absolutely the only way you can win you
cannot do this stuff while you're doing
six things at once no one wins doing
this I have walked more people out of
debt in North America than any other two
people put together I know what I'm
doing on this well I've got an opinion I
don't care what your opinion is it's
America you have the right to be wrong I
have an experience and a man with an
experience is not at the mercy of a man
with an opinion the way you get out of
debt the most sure probability of
reasonable success on getting out of
debt is complete focus stop investing
stop saving until your debt free then
you build your emergency fund in baby
step 3 so high callers and other hours
call me they got $15,000 in the bank and
they say they're working baby step 2 no
you're not
that's not the definition of baby step
two that is not what we teach take the
money out of that stinkin bank account
and pay it on those debts down to a
thousand dollars on your smallest to
your largest debt get out of debt that's
baby step two I don't have anything to
my name except my retirement accounts
that I'm no longer adding to temporarily
and the thousand dollars that's all I've
got
I've got twenty five thousand mutual
funds you think gotta pay that on my
debt yes that's what I've been saying I
got an extra I got my emergency fund
built and I'm in baby step two no you're
not baby step two you don't have an
emergency fund built-in baby step two
the definition of baby step two is all
your money came out of everything except
retirement and went on to the debts that
is the definition of baby step two why
am I so this is the only way it works
you can't screw around and try to do
three things at once you don't get any
of them done focus that's what wins
folks that's what wins that's what wins
while we teach it over and over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over again that's why this worse stuff
works then and only then baby step 40
you start your retirement savings kids
college to pay off your house survey
five six seven